ding-ding-ding-ding ding-ding-ding-ding
so apparently watch this you say Frank
you say ding ding ding ding ding he's
gonna make an epic ding song win
everyone welcome back to the Jen Gillian
podcast with our special guest this week
80 fits sup everybody uh we actually
discussed you on the last podcast with
Jane we did and what we did you did we
well we have all did you might have been
watching but you're still in the
commerce well I think that the funny the
funny thing is I think you you you made
a comment that I definitely probably
wasn't watching the podcast and I
definitely do you uh you called me out
you know any time my name is mentioned
on the Internet
I find it you know if you're mentioning
funding building Google Alerts yeah
brain like there's an alert sense I know
yeah god this week's episode of brought
to you by nature box guys remember in
each box over 100 delicious awesome
snacks sent right to your door go to
naturebox.com/tyler Julianne get two
bags of snacks for free try it out guys
my favorite guns are young lemon Santa
fake corn um Jenna likes them too
yeah when Shane me to sprinkle them on
Chipotle we've got the last nature box
once we change that is so they're bad
guys go get yourself some H box
naturebox.com/tyler and Julian will show
you some snacks later also brought to
you by headspace guys heads bases guided
meditation really helps you stay calm
reduce stress go to headspace calm slash
annejulien and try to take ten challenge
for ten days of free guided meditation
right from your phone
rosters woo-woo-woo we have eighty fits
here if you don't know eighty fits is
eighty fits is with your name's Andrew
but you go by eighty fits oh no one
knows that that's a secret it's actually
not cuz you do lady pants and that comes
so nice try I tried to keep it a secret
but yeah it's partly - and I am DV
everyone like that's what happened I
mean you go go succeed at things and
then there's no more secret I still like
to pretend like I don't actually have a
name like I was just given a number
eighty is like you should get like like
that tattooed on your body like a
barcode so then you that's like real
numb I've thought about getting eighty
just stamped right I'm not referring to
my ass yeah better idea eight zero right
right around the eyes yeah like maybe
like a side oh my god
yes an infinite just to see that that's
taste boy ah you're a beatbox are really
awesomely talented beatbox uh who got a
ton of popularity from being online
moving a beatboxing - no Julia really
really cool
I love how like a lot of different
people you know have their different
reasons for gaining followings on things
like find and yours was just beatboxing
yeah you uh you grew up with Jay are you
yes yeah no um so it was Ju Alaska it
was our last last kiss yes yes so um Jay
is like my number one homey
I've known Jason's like third grade and
we went to elementary school middle
school high school together and he
played in a band with my brother so I've
known Jay and his family forever
Jay played in a band tape yeah Jay was
the front man in a band Bob we [ __ ]
June oh my god we [ __ ] blew that it
was your job to ask about the band
Jay Jay walk down to misdemeanors you
should check out really super old-school
like high school testing yeah it's
awesome like I'm gonna check that out
for sure so there's this one song I saw
so far yeah desire to death and I just
want to wait you did say something about
that to me one time ways aren't you - uh
it might be I don't know but Jay Walker
the misdemeanours best man name ever
that is a pretty good name yeah so
without Hughes in a band with your
brother with my brother my brother is a
pretty dope drummer and
yeah they jammed out all through college
because my brother and J went to school
together and then yeah and then when I
came back after college J and I started
just like we reconnected just children
oh my god we really yes
J is watching which he is that he
wouldn't waste this tiny way miss this
time wait so this is Jay this is Jay Oh
Delia espana every time you smile and
know why oh yeah yeah that's good that
is good my brother drumming I don't know
if that was my brother I think that was
the first drummer that like not only the
first time yeah yeah brother alder
younger he's younger yes yeah he's two
years younger than me I could you know
so you and Jay moved out to LA together
not together
no I we actually learned that I learned
that when I first met you guys yeah yeah
I I was like the little of the tag along
like a year and a half later so so he
was the guinea pig though he was a
guinea pig yeah he he moved out and I
was still working a desk job like in a
monkey suit just like crunching numbers
just beatboxing your head beatbox what
was it what was that job what was your
former life I was a business analyst I
was important mins and kid shoes from
childhood oh I mean you could have
walked down that life path imagine what
it would have been something [ __ ] lit
I I mean just imagine I used as the
cubicle mate
just hearing that all day I I just
actually depending on how you look at it
well I tried never to beatbox when I was
in my cube or doing during meetings but
I definitely would get ideas and I would
go in the bathroom when no one was there
and I would just shred for like five
minutes video back okay so how does one
start ever beatboxing like in their
whole entire life like how did you learn
that you have came for it uh I don't
think I like I don't think I had an
aptitude for beatboxing and it's not
something that just like boom I could do
it yeah like I was in choir class like
ironically with Jay and some other
people and like when I was like 15 or 16
and so I actually started late because I
didn't even really know what be boxing
and we saw some acapella some acapella
groups and then they had guys that were
just going like we were like oh that's
crazy because yeah we couldn't go back
in the day so so cool
um I'm not saying it's cool to hear it
in person yeah I'm gonna make you guys
learn oh yeah I'm excited
um so yeah we we saw some acapella
groups and we kind of got really
interested in trying to learn how to do
it because there's basic like minimal
beatboxing and some of our our choir
arrangements and we kind of got obsessed
with it and I remember beatboxing with
Jay Ashley back in high school he was
like way better than me and um yeah he
was better than he was dope yeah he was
super that he's like like he could do C
sub and Ice Cube kicked out of choir
class all the time for beatboxing sorry
yeah my too lame he was about it that's
that's really I mean I feel like people
who are like better than they should be
at something any age like that they're
normally kicked out of class for David I
think it was cuz cuz I sucked really bad
I was probably terrible your teacher is
like give advising it's barley sounded
like farts yeah
and then obviously Brian came along yeah
and you're like oh I could do it on here
yeah I did I actually had a YouTube
channel and I had some solos on there
that like actually did okay like I had a
couple that like had 50 200k views and
but like I wasn't a youtuber social
media person by any means and then once
I moved out to LA I was working on music
with Jay and we released an album
together actually you did
what's it called oh you know that no
yeah yeah that's the sole reason I moved
on job was me
take on these podcaster someone's
dropping the ball yeah the sole reason I
moved out to LA was to produce and write
music which is what I still do outside
of honor yes like that's my whole that's
my whole life's goal is just to write so
I moved out and Jay and I wrote an album
over like two years and then we I moved
out to release it and finish it with Jay
and we started vining to promote the
album
and so the beatboxing was just this sort
of like happy accident I think it was
sort of the hook like hey look here's a
guy that beat boxes in kind of does
comedy but like once I've got you like
now listen to my music interesting thing
it was kind of a weird thing that's
crazy
shows you the album's done albums out
yeah yeah Jay it's we Jay and I together
were and are the digital kicks digital
yes ki ck k ck yeah and digital kicks
and it's called losing gravity and it's
like this concept album and all the
songs like flow together and I spent
like way too much of my life on it but
and then you went to buy these as a
means to an end like this is to promote
yeah yeah that's a divine completely
took yes a vine took on a life of its
own and then it led to a bunch of other
stuff and the digital kicks like still
exists and the album is still there and
I still stand by it but we've kind of
since moved on to I understandably yeah
but that's cool we might come back and
do an album instead if I want are you
guys for a party would you want to play
I can do a little bit yeah I can detail
III I have like a mixer and I have track
yeah we were talking about that that's
badass
yeah I can do I can't really scratch but
I can epital but I can do that oh my god
and bring so you you had no like
entertainment or acting experience
before you moved out here no I still
can't really and so you are not this
perfect that I get [ __ ] to lie to
yourself oh yeah if it's really - okay
so how do you know that that's a crazy
story actually that's one of those like
that's one of those LA stories that you
hear about on on like James Corden or
something random like thing that just
what happened was I was uh I was working
at Guitar Center corporate and corporate
like John I didn't even know because I
had moved out I even the one with a I
said no wait this no no I was like again
I was back in the cube for like two
months because like I was I was vining
and the out hid roots release the album
but I didn't get the publishing deal I
wanted and you know I I figured like I
was kind of a little bit lower on cash I
was like you know I'll go back and I'll
work a desk job and still grind so it's
like sleeping like three or four hours a
night and it's working Guitar Center
team making music and bonny and I got
hit up by Ben Bram who's since become
one of my friend a really good friend
yeah Ben Bram is like this sing off
pitch perfect one and pentatonix and
he's like so he manages he arranges
pinball pentatonic stuff what yeah he's
super super ill and he hit oh yeah like
Grammy level he's won two Grammys he's
super Idol that's an easy so he
contacted you contacted me about the
sing-off because he was trying he's
always on vine and it's such a good [ __ ]
yeah yes okay
yeah a cliche David did we used to watch
this show and make so much fun Nikola
Jude fast-forward through the opening
and he's like I mean I need agrees was
kind of fire back in the day yeah I used
to watch him on what was the reality
show we had with Jessica Simpson oh yeah
yeah yeah she was a newlyweds yeah which
I want to phenomena Oh Nick Lachey
alright enough about Nick Lachey's back
to your sorry oh yeah yeah okay so so
Ben brown hits me up hits Jay and I both
up about being on the sing-off he wanted
to create some sort of like vine
acapella group and presented on the
sing-off bit and Jay and I were in the
midst of releasing the album we're like
not it's not the lane we want so I
respectfully declined but I was like hey
Ben if you ever need me for anything
beatboxing related hit me up in the
future and so it wasn't until like three
four months later when I was kind of
like at a low point working at Guitar
Center and just like crunching numbers
again
that he hit me up and like hey we have
this I have this crazy opportunity for
pitch perfect - have you seen the first
one and I was like yeah it's like one of
my favorite movies he ever yeah and he
was like yeah um you know we really
liked your stuff and we kind of were
interested in maybe having you do the
soundtrack but also maybe being in the
film
would you be willing to go to this dance
audition [ __ ] and no ho dance audition
minutes audition to beatbox
that's like yesterday I didn't know what
the hell I whine [ __ ] so yeah so I went
dance no prepare for an audition and the
craziest thing the answer I'll show oh
so so my sister my sister was is a
fantastic dancer and she's the only
person I told I was like yo I'm going to
this dance audition for like pitch
perfect - I don't know what it's for but
they kind of like maybe are thinking
about putting me in the movie and so I
went to NoHo met up with this intense
ask choreographer and he had these like
crazy German hip-hop moves to this
insane acapella arrangement and I didn't
know what the hell I was doing and it
was me and this girl Ali feeder who is
also in the group with me and she's
become one of my super good friends
awesome and at the time we didn't know
each other but we we had this intense
choreography together and after like
that an hour and a half of like getting
destroyed by this dude he he put us on
camera
and and it was like I left that audition
being like there's no chance I [ __ ] it
up you all the way flavor like now yeah
I mean you should it was the sloppiest
worst thing like I felt like I felt like
it was it it was comparable to like
getting in the highest like the highest
level of like a French lesson and then
having to go and like present till I had
like all in the span yeah yeah it's like
presenting a presentation in French
after learning like a few vocab words
and then so obviously they called you
back yeah so five it wasn't till like
five weeks later I got a call on a
Thursday from casting and they were like
hey uh Fitz um we this is Cavallaro
casting callin calling you about pitch
42 we need you on a plane on Monday
you're going bathroom so I was like in
my cube I went to the bathroom and like
was hyperventilating and I went into my
car called my parents and I was like yo
you'll never believe what happened and
then I quit my job the next day and I
was in Baton Rouge on Monday Wow it was
just like a whirlwind and I it saved me
from having to work the cube again that
is so that's a really great story it's
really [ __ ] cool in saying it was
[ __ ] Reno cool like opportunity meets
proximity and talent meet it's kind of a
whole perfect storm definitely it was
definitely just right place the right -
yeah and there's a lot of luck involved
with that I think yeah for sure but it's
also like I love how the universe like
the second that you're like really down
and need something the universe is like
yeah [ __ ] bum kid yeah for sure I'm
sure
just when you think your life is like I
this is it this is my life for not is
gonna suck I mean it's it's very easy to
say you know be humble about say I was a
perfect place perfect time kind of very
lucky thing but what you don't think
about when that sort of thing happens is
like all the times and places that
didn't work out which could be Millions
you know I mean like all the times all
the moments that just never worked out
and turned in anything
finally one did and then any the odds
are yeah that's absolutely true
and like I had been busting my ass on
vine for a year and putting out
consistent content trying to improve the
quality and make sure that like the 80
fits brand was this solid this solid
brand where people could go for a
certain level of quality and see like
the other verso bull your [ __ ] I mean
what's cool is you're beatboxing is
obviously your thing you're good at it
that's your skill but you've you've
meshed it into making really cool lines
like but when you post the other day
where you had the pet whoo deception is
so cool ridiculous it was like what was
your home Italian and it like popped out
that was a headache man that was I would
look like it in like no you did that
seamless like I was watching it over and
I'm like how like this is really well
done you thank you that was probably my
craziest vine production ever like took
two-and-a-half months to shoot because
you went I went to all this place yeah
no yeah people were like yo he learned
how to use a green screen cuz I was like
oh [ __ ] you [ __ ] guys had on so many
planes I'm [ __ ] Wayne uh hell no no
I'm not trying to I'm not trying to
cheat that's awesome now
and that was I was a brandy fine right
no the the first one I did was a branded
vine it was just an excuse to do a thing
I had wanted to do forever okay and so
HP sent me some laptops and were like
hey do a thing
gato cares man the idea so that was like
people kind of people kind of griped
about the second and third one like
thinking it was branded but they weren't
it was just me doing it Sam so [ __ ]
cool thank you
that is cool um you know it's also
poised like delicious snacks that was
the best segue naturebox has all your
delicious snack needs guys go to
naturebox octagon confess jenna Julie
and you get your first two bags of
snacks for free they have over a hundred
choices for snacks and guys it you know
everyone's been to the store trying to
find a healthy snacks looking through
labels all this nature box cuts all
those problems out for you they present
you all these options online some of our
favorites they're vegan they have a lot
of vegan snacks which is great because
Jenna's begin and I'm trying my best
or I didn't know that yeah what how long
uh on and off since 2009 and like on
solid for almost a year now yeah Santa
Fe corn steak is impressive delicious
matter spec and being I was happy
it's nobody's okay it's definitely tough
to find convenient good snacks yeah as a
vegan so naturebox has and they have the
little stamp on it when you're looking
through it has me and mark so guys check
out nature box one in a shoe box calm
slash annejulien get your first two bags
of snacks for free and tell us how
delicious they are tweeted at us
whatever you want
thank you so much to nature ox response
for the podcast once again this podcast
is also brought to you by headspace guys
it's great to get some headspace and
with the headspace app is made simple
it's guided meditation you need to right
from your phone your smartphone your
tablet or your computer you just bring
your headphones and you plug it in and
they help you they guide you through the
meditation which a lot of people don't
realize how much of an effect that can
have especially in a day and age where
we're constantly on our phones not that
that's a bad thing it's just a thing and
so when you can get 10 minutes away from
all that and really kind of relax your
mind meditate that will help you with it
it is so unbelievable you have to try it
go to headspace calm / Jenna Julian to
do the take 10 challenge that's ten days
of free guided meditation and like I
said you could do it from anywhere fear
it works you're on an airplane do it on
the airplane do it in the car there's no
injury road trip and you want to leave
your cubicle go to the bathroom you get
some headspace hell yeah and just sit in
the stall and then make the noises or
don't make the noises it is weird
everyone ah it doesn't even matter
because you're getting headspace okay ah
I can't tell you how many times I
actually did that I would go to the
bathroom and just Center myself in the
stall
not everyone has moments like that like
you had so many jobs that I had I used
the bathroom as like an excuse to just
[ __ ] get away if you at work I was
doing yep so if you want to do that and
get headspace go try for free right now
guys headspace Khan's last challenge ng
sponte Thank You sponsors much
appreciated okay so you have to teach us
a little bit like enough so that we
don't look how absolutely ridiculous
okay okay but okay so you you obviously
just go like am I saying all right now
you can just go my god um yeah it's like
that's [ __ ] okay there's no it's also
it's also deeply ingrained by this yeah
I think it's like a psyche it's at this
point it's like it's like speaking it's
like speaking a second language it is a
language it's like I always tell people
if I'm doing like a fast beat it can
translate into a sentence like there's
been other beatboxers who have talked
about this too but it's like like Boone
Dibby Dibby Dibby Dibby Dibby Dibby
whatever the limit interpreted over to
my data better to be diverted boom like
that sort of thing yeah that's okay what
when you say in prayers noise it's mind
blowing
yeah no like you guys are getting it's
cool you're hearing it from where you
are but being in the room right now it's
very good fun in mine when you say
professionally boxers who are some
professionally bachas that you um got to
or have followed or by yes it's crazy
because a lot of the beatboxers that I
really looked up to when I was in high
school or in college when I was really
starting to learn was uh was a lot of
Europeans mm-hmm because the the boxing
with beatboxing was huge over there yeah
and still is but it was like big in
Europe first and there's this UK beat
boxer was like a 2-time UK champ his
name's beardyman and he's like insane
reached one shout out to reaps one so
when you say champ there's like a
national beatbox
oh yeah there's worlds like a god and I
used to I battled in the 2011 American
meet Bosch damages Wow and where was
that it was in New York City [ __ ] yeah
okay how do we note it and can you break
down how that like oh it's super dope
and yeah me made top 16 in 2012 but I
didn't actually battle I came out to LA
to forge on that's so many good that's
[ __ ] cool so I mean if you need
another proof that you're legit I mean
that stuff yeah I mean it's like a lot
of people don't know that I was a battle
beat boxer first and people which is
kind of which is kind of shitty cuz like
I still have a lot of loyalty to the
community and a lot of the a lot of beat
boxers like a younger kids who are like
14 like I've been in the game for like
10 years I was like these young kids who
don't know and they and they're like oh
if it's just a vine beatboxer and they
don't know that I was like when you say
80 fits you put some respect on his
missus
no I'm just kidding I mean that's that's
like that's like your internet cross to
bear like vine has done a lot to you but
it's also that thing like people think
I'm only this yeah yeah it's true but um
yeah you know I've been out of the
battle scene for a while I haven't
battle in two years but I still go I
went to the Canadian champion November I
went up to Toronto and really cool but
the battles are insane like I cannot
like [ __ ] him it's like all the these
hip-hop heads and all the beat boxers
from like around the the country will go
and they all meet up everyone's jamming
everybody's watching sharing techniques
like and there's trends like new sounds
will kind of sweep the beatbox community
and is so cool and yeah there's judges
and everyone gets hype it's it's crazy
it's so dope that must be like the most
incredible feeling when you're up there
and just killing it
yeah yeah I mean when I when I was in
college my my acapella group allowed me
to do beatbox solos at every huge show
and my last show I think was like a soul
that was like 2,400 people is a man and
I had like a 5 year in college yeah and
I was just it was insane and I got a
standing O at the end and I like got
misty it was inside to him and five
minutes of beatboxing though yeah it's
like you know you build a routine and
then sort of I never really follow it
precisely but it's always sort about
this [ __ ] cool really [ __ ] cool
I'll get tired yes of what I what what
muscles get the most tired when you
beatbox is it like you're throwing your
cheek so your mouth like that throat
basin in word dududu those are all
breathing okay that's inward okay okay
don't go go like that sound yeah that
sound will cuz all that nice rough
vibration yeah cuz it's um like uh it's
like a wheezing sound and it tears up my
throat but yeah
you know I'll be happy because it's like
that sound did they do they did it like
sounds crazy to be yeah also like so
anything involving like deep throat
sounds yeah every right and like you get
every boo-boo
yeah I just want to hear you [ __ ] son
of a GM already all right so if you're
gonna teach us to be boxed water how do
we start what is like give me something
to do so I don't knows you guys I just
want to be like you kids okay okay give
me step 1 beatboxing such a weird scale
uh like never comes in handy outside of
like social media that's not true no
girl awesome no girl has ever been on a
date and then like a beatbox from hey
beatboxers like as we box real sexy
exact sexy beatboxing is like impossibly
maybe like Oh baby
it's like it make some creepy and
awesome yeah it's somebody out there
just got to make into that yeah yeah so
uh beatbox lessons all right all right
I'll teach you guys the basic the boots
and cats that's what everyone learns to
when it's the simplified so basically
what you're what you're doing is you're
just saying boots and cats it's like the
schools
yeah and you're saying you're basically
just hitting the hard consonant in the B
and the C cat so like boots boots and
you hit that the T on that boot and adds
sin so they're just to be be tea tea tea
yet be T C tea
alright cool so just yeah yeah that's
that's that's essentially it that's it
it's that simple put you to do it with
me so they can't tell if it's so good
you just keep going the key the key with
the key with are we tryna yeah the key
with making a really crisp tight sound
is just building up a lot of pressure in
your
so if you're saying uh if you're saying
boots but most people just have a soft
be know when you're beatboxing it has to
be like God you just don't really ants
it's really that's it yeah don't
laughing you're making me self-conscious
or somewhere that's that's Ashley that
yeah
that's that's good okay that's hard
this is [ __ ] hard ways harder than
clarity I mean you make it sound so
[ __ ] seamless yeah just kind of
insane um yeah so that that's the basic
that's the basic beat just the basic
rock I like doing it when you do it and
then when you get more advanced yes WI
so your internal rhythm like your
metronome must be incredible like is
that something you consciously develop
uh yes yeah I feel like I have a really
bad time but um
you sounded like GarageBand I like the
way you just up the beat count per
whatever I don't like in terms of this
it sounds like it's [ __ ] seamlessness
five units out so when I'm beatboxing
outside of a metronome I'm decent but
like if I have to be a super super on
like in studio sometimes like really
really slow Timbo's mess me up like if
I'm doing it 60 BPM super ultra slow
whatever the hell that is yeah that's
real it's hard stuff yeah but yeah
faster it's easier alright so you want
to beatbox a song and have us guess what
song well I mean okay what like what you
do
yeah I am useless several everyone knows
this one I think everyone knew that I I
think we might get popped for copyright
that was so good like that was
ridiculous oh the beatbox beatbox
classic a lot of be monsters I've done
this really good beatboxing so how do
you [ __ ] do the clicking noise what
how you yes so the multitasking is
[ __ ] I think well that took me a lot
of people's minds when you're doing one
they're like okay but then you add like
a voice yeah yeah all right time you
hear someone like making words all your
beatbox
that's the I think that's one of the
toughest things like comprehend yeah
that one that took a long time when I
was first learning because the humming
humming and beatboxing it is pretty
challenging for people at first because
like sustaining a note that's reducing
yes you you eventually get to a point
where I'm not I'm not thinking about the
beat I'm just thinking about the humming
so I'm thinking about just modulating my
voice like and the beat is like must be
yeah The Beeches muscle memory it's just
like me
almost counting counting or keeping time
in my head and I don't think about the
hits huh so like it's just it's just
like a vibe so if I'm kind of doing like
it's just whatever melody comes to my
head I've actually never broken down my
beatboxing in this much detail really
yeah so this is some top secret Chika's
you're welcome okay so I don't know at
first so clearly you do spend your time
questionably watching this podcast I'm
just gay
you watch this podcast at least the one
with Jay and you've seen it so you know
that we do have a I mean pretty dope
theme song so if you were to like break
down that theme song do you do you know
what it is like how can you give me a
refresher yeah cuz ding ding did you
think that you don't have the audio
silencing I think I do you know what I
think I do
Danny find it in people cuz I want to
hear nervous I'm gonna play it for you I
think I have many stones dink-dink
mashup yes yeah point that clap point I
can't stop I develop this really bad
habit like this whenever I saw something
it's really up super I accept our class
at that point but at the end of this
house kind of it looked very good
reggae are you yeah this was in the
YouTube library of free music so oh this
is gonna be libraries ok yeah like break
oh it gets crazy like it oh my god
you like throwing the train hmm
something like that
okay the deep end
I don't even know what just happened
thank you for putting up with us just
being like putting you on the spot over
and over half I appreciated that you're
just like here doing it and it's no
problem
ah that was [ __ ] cool My Mind's
number one we should overlay that audio
to the beginning of this thing
Bing Bing does got it okay okay yeah
Jenna Jenna just do do a little dink
tank I'll drop a beat and then we're
gonna julienne we'll just go in and
maybe do a little like freestyle oh [ __ ]
work anytime zone it ain't a job set job
addicted
go dink dink dink dink dink dink dink
there we go dink dink dink dink dink
dink dink dink dink dink dink dink dink
dink dink dink dink dink dink dink dink
you have your son we so bad we like like
said that one when episode ding ding
clay we keep wordid on how this sounds
and now it's a thing when people call it
the dink fan dk4 ding famil ding ding
ding ding ding
that was [ __ ] dope dude that was
really cool all right so moving like on
for you like you obviously have your
music gave your vines is there anything
you're working on right now that is
exciting yeah yeah I'm working on a
talking about completely new thing
I'm not a teef it's it's it's outside of
80 fits and it's like my personal EP
like my own oh [ __ ] yeah so it's going
to be hopefully coming out and next like
I want to say like three to four months
but my tentative is I have like probably
1015 songs but we're just trying to like
yeah narrow it down so did you like make
all of that you say produce and write
yeah yeah you do a lot of it yourself
yeah I did all the production and knock
all the writing yeah so I mean you ever
need someone and drop you so much Andy
do my beats heard rose you great over
music she just comes up with yes no way
is so [ __ ] mad at spire though
it is not fire okay give yourself like a
little bitter kind of fire for I know
that if he says their fire therefore a
YouTube video and I'll do them like
quickly they don't really I spend a lot
of time Blackie's no she was like he's
but she does like she mixes in beat fees
so I've seen I mean I don't you can't
know because is that with the with the
buttons and you like they're talking
about yeah yeah like you like play with
a MIDI controls not usually no she got
mad that I should get you should
definitely make a beat making it like
Jenna makes beats that be saying I
should be found it would be so much like
that'd be so much fun what you did today
guys I'm gonna make a beat and then just
like get get a machine and just like
start banging those stupidest these
things look so much fun
like I made you that you probably buy
them and they just a guitar said yeah I
just rang the juicer machine claps that
point Guitar Center yep yep nice that
are basically fun to this whole podcast
we get everything from yeah yeah who's
rebar Mike's everything yeah but it's
where I used to work I know that's why
we retro actively remembered that you
work there so every time you shop there
we feature assume no dude will call on
you for help on that because that's on
that would be so much fun that would be
very fun I'm imagining it just like all
the pieces coming together and it's like
everything sounds and like kind of dumb
and weird yeah at the end it's like the
dopest it's just I'm satisfied yeah and
then yo you did you did a rap though
bouncy Oh dick back in the day oh my god
that [ __ ] was fire as I know you can rap
I know you can rap god bouncy Oh dick is
fire if you haven't seen that it's like
the best thing Oh Julian uh what No
oh I'm gonna [ __ ]
so this is breaking the rule number one
we're not supposed to play to other
stuff but you have rule number one no I
hate everyone
I hate every day I quit hey I spend my
morning shake it back safe in your bars
okay
I wrote something like 15 [ __ ]
minutes on the way over that's a
testament to the fact that you see what
no you don't even need to put effort and
it sounds legit like I'm sorry no idea
my dad my trying to talk here am i
trying to talk the roast video aside
from the [ __ ] 24 hour straight that
we spent shooting and editing you put a
day and a half straight into making that
song and it's dope yeah cuz dope song
well I'd only took me that long because
all the volume was [ __ ] up late at
night and fix it
that's what I'm saying I'm sorry I'm
sorry for bringing up bouncy Oh dick I'm
just a huge fan of bouncy Oh dick thank
you for giving any shoes please actually
people say that though and it's [ __ ]
weird man it's only so vulgar but it's
viral it sounds dope oh yeah it was a
little bit of fits on that track and
yeah it's a good then like every time
Ryan Higa comes here he puts out on the
[ __ ] dude then we all we all play
that game when he comes to physics we
put everyone's [ __ ] on it he played
myself in there say dance video
[ __ ] no okay Jeff really can tell your
friends no sudden they start watching
one of your like things and really guys
that's the work later didn't I'm sorry I
Darrell I brought you agree if you can
I'm in trouble don't worry about you're
fine um but if ya did if you're down to
help us out that would be I would love
to they good to see they're super fun I
think people would dig it too I think it
would be the best thing and I think it'd
be the best thing in the world like you
could you could do literally anything I
have like so many ideas of the top that
could be like super super fun so what do
we need to do that I just want you
should get you a key thing what is it
called
I have a machine I have like the path
you can just literally like that play
cuz you pick what's so cool you can
sample it yeah we could several marbles
or something oh my god I can have that
squeaky before her yes play like that
that's like my goal in life is to be
gene or whatever his name is from Bob's
Burgers that walks around with the
keyboard and it just goes up
yes yes that's what it is yeah yeah
sample your [ __ ] sounds and make
something dub you could be fun it makes
a really cool so this EP I'm really
curious
so you said next couple months you know
obviously let us know what you guys know
when it's out but yeah its first time
I've released music if you were to say
yeah doing all that so if you were to
put in like one sentence how it's very
quiet how it's different from your
content right now like how would you how
would you differentiate why is it um
it's just it's heavier it takes itself
it doesn't take itself more seriously
but it's just heavier themes it's
heavier sounding it's more electronic
it's it there's minimal to no beatboxing
and just on my production you wouldn't
even know you have no idea with me card
you have no idea was a teef it's got it
got it got I mean you're what you're
trying to do is be more than 85th yeah
I'm making this music the goal the goal
for me has always been to try to like I
want to be Diplo I want like Diplo is
one of my heroes and I want I want to I
want to have a Diplo in a Major Lazer
and a Jack you and have all these
projects and like no one even know that
yeah that it's in Andrew Fitzpatrick
it's like you know I want yeah I would
love people to hear me on the radio and
then later find out holy [ __ ] that's a
tea that's the Nazi Club to do it's a
really cool thing I know you're talking
about and I think that's [ __ ] - so
like the project's called Westland and
it's like this weird it's it's it's this
weird sort of like take on my LA and
like Vegas experience and sort of like
how everything is sort of like neon
plastic and fake but there's like
moments of like genuine sincerity in
this weird city so it's like this weird
introspective project but I think I
think it's I stand by it I really like
the song [ __ ] really hyped up nos that's
awesome I'm excited to see that
well definitely else and you got some
tests please keep us posted on that will
keep policy awesome oh so you guys a
tune after this view okay yeah yeah well
do you thank you so much for joining us
for the podcast
really cool of us I can't wait to get an
8 and then have my mouth be a zero
tattoo
well you better like copyrighted cuz
everyone's gonna start doing that yo did
you see did you see that one crazy girl
who got Drake okay that was one of my
favorite Halloween costumes though like
a year later some girl just did like
braids and wrote trick on me fate like
that is the best like last-minute
holiday good gosh yes it's so obscure
but people would get it it's like yeah
it's like a neverending story Joe people
that [ __ ] with neverending story yes
those inside jokes for the best yeah so
I guess next is the cover of your album
gonna be your face with the ink yeah
that's just going to be of course not
it's not gonna be that 79 it's one your
your tattoo appointment for that isn't
until like the fall right I am too this
is not 85th that's separate yeah it's a
separate thing
yeah well I'm really excited to hear
what you come up with and as always like
your content is really dope and we're
gonna link your bind your Twitter and
everything guys go check them out he's
really really cool stuff and yeah dude
thanks again thank you guys awesome it
was these things and [ __ ] it up
more seriously let's do it let's make me
I know I do I don't um [ __ ] don't
play with that yeah oh yeah I'm not a
party talker so let's make this dude and
then we can get Jay to do some buckles
on track oh let's just yo we're gonna
[ __ ] it taught me a lot of things
twelve rows are super [ __ ] me you're
watching but so you're in his oh [ __ ]
alright guys well thank you for hanging
out for another week like I said check
out fits of stuff in the description
below and check out our sponsors thank
you to our sponsors nation at edge days
we will see you guys next week for
another podcast dink dink and gate dink
dink dink dink dink dink dink dink dink
dink dink dink dink dink dink dink dink
ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding
ding ding ding dude ain't eating oh my
god
hell yeah ha ha ha alright bye daddy